devait recevoir aussi mon invité du soir
il a co créé attention l'assistant vocal
de la fameuse marque à la pomme vous
savez un machin dis moi quel est bien
c'est oui et il est français merci
d'accueillir les gels à dire c'est que
la télé alors vous publiez duke aux
éditions first l'intelligence
artificielle n'existe pas ou vous
répondait à toutes les questions que
l'on se pose sur ce concept ce fameux
concept dit à intelligence artificielle
dont on entend parler un petit peu
partout mais on entend énormément parler
mais est ce qu'on sait vraiment ce que
c'est que l'adhésion artificiel je ne
suis pas certaine alors justement c'est
quoi cette fameuse intelligence
artificielle qu'est ce que ça veut dire
qu'est ce que c'est ben justement elle
n'existe pas abbas et la première donc
donc le l'intelligence je sais quoi faut
se poser la question regarder jamie
mohamed vous avez la définition comme on
ne sait pas ce que c'est qu'un
intelligence on peut pas la définir
c'est très difficile de définir et de
créer une intelligence artificielle
bien sûr vous vous dites même arte
l'intelligence plutôt plutôt
qu'artificielle augmenté oui parce que
en fait ce qu'on a pu créer avec des
ordinateurs parce qu'il ya quelques
chapelles le machine learning by
planning c'est ce concret comme capcom
comme ceux discipline aujourd'hui ça ça
augmente notre hôte et j'en sais pas ce
que ça fait c'est que les machines vont
être là pour nous augmenter pour nous
aider et le voici qui tient notre
service exactement pour qu'on soit
encore j'allais dire la meilleure
voilà ça c'est dans le meilleur des
mondes oui il faut pas être un
bisounours donc voit pas non plus
exagérer et puis dire que tout va être
super et donc il faut faire attention il
faut c'est du quai mais en gros oui la
technologie et celle là en particulier
est là pour nous aider d'accord très
bien alors ils ont évidemment énormément
de questions à vous poser parce qu'ils
se sont plongés dans votre livre on est
était passionné et on va commencer par
damien ou une petite question me tarde
que lorsque l'on créé une ronde de oui
exactement des d'accord lorsque l'on
créé une application de commande vocale
qui est utilisé par plus de 500 millions
de personnes à travers le monde à ce que
l'on est aussi riche que bill gates avec
lausanne qui vous intéresse on est
d'accord et la savoie tarn
c'est une question réponse est non ah
parce que sinon je serai l'homme le plus
riche du monde
donc non mais ça va justement sur 7 sur
cette application cette commande vocale
comment est ce que vous en avez eu
l'idée comment est ce que vous vous êtes
dit je vais nous les humains on va
parler un ordinateur il va comprendre ce
qu'on lui rappelle ce qu'on lui raconte
et il va nous apporter une réponse
vocale
alors ça fait longtemps qu'on essaye on
essaie depuis les années 50 donc ça fait
très longtemps mais quand on a créé le
concept de syrie en 97 c'était un petit
moment on a eu l'idée parce que internet
venait d'arriver globalement en 94 et on
s'est dit comment interrogé correctement
internet est le plus naturelle du monde
c'était juste de poser la voix et donc
on s'est dit on va utiliser
c'est comme ça ça a l'air tout simple
oui mais encore une fois c'est une
discipline on essayait depuis longtemps
on n'avait pas vraiment le domaine
d'application et l'a interrogé internet
c'était naturel c'était bien et ça a été
relativement facile
oui oui pour vous thibault également eu
une peur avec la montée en puissance
dans tous les domaines de justement de
cette intelligence artificielle est ce
que un jour les robots vont prendre le
contrôle sur l'homme n'ont donc là
clairement avec ce qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui donc aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle tacaille
défini ce sont des mathématiques et de
statistique de base d'accords donc c'est
c'est quelque chose que nous contrôlons
nous programmons les machines nous
décidons qu'elle data on leur donne nous
déciderons absolument tout elles ne
pourront pas parce qu'on l'a vu parfois
il y compris dans des films de fiction
la machine qui prend le pas sur l'homme
et qui finalement s'autogère et n'a plus
besoin de l'homme pour être pour coder
pour et elle se crée elle même donc vous
venez le job dans des films de fiction
monclar donc à hollywood
oui c'est très bien ça va c'est comme ça
c'est super mais dans la vraie vie dans
les techniques qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
il ya absolument aucune chance dans les
techniques nouvelles qu'on peut inventer
demain on verra
et aujourd'hui aucune chance donc ya pas
besoin d'avoir peur voilà thibault l'ag